to California city wants to use drones
to help save lives Palo Alto hopes to
become the first US city to use unmanned
aircraft to deliver blood from a blood
bank to a hospital the Federal Aviation
Administration is reviewing the city's
proposal along with about a hundred and
fifty others the agency will approve ten
projects to move forward next month but
as Midea video shows us some worry that
more drones could create more harm this
could be the future of healthcare drones
delivering blood in emergencies at the
Stanford Blood Center in the heart of
Silicon Valley dr. Tom's team collects
about 200 pints of blood each day most
of that supply is stored at the hospital
but sometimes there's a need for more
you can't plan for emergencies and
that's where time becomes even more
crucial right now they use a courier
service but the process can be slow the
depends on the time of day courier
availability traffic conditions anywhere
from 30 to 60 minutes and with a drone
the drone 10 minutes or less this is a
huge difference it's a huge difference
and it it can make a difference in a lot
of people's lives
Andres rep topless is the CEO of drone
delivery company matter net he showed us
how it works the blood would be placed
in a secure box and automatically loaded
into the drone before taking off on a
pre-programmed route at the hospital
doctors use a QR code on their phone to
unlock and grab the package is he paying
one three several of the projects the
FAA is now considering deal with
healthcare drone delivery companies
zipline which is involved in eight
different proposals says their drones
can fly over a hundred miles to shuttle
medical supplies to rural communities
under current federal law drones must
stay in the operators line-of-sight but
next month the FAA would waive those
restrictions for the ten pilot projects
opening up the possibilities for
commercial drone use in the US
regulators still have to tackle though
those tough questions about privacy and
safety there's no telling what can
happen Palo Alto resident Katie Talbott
who lives near their proposed route is
concerned I think they know that they
would run into a lot of resistance from
the neighborhood if they tried to fly
over them with a load of blood matter
net says the route will be over open
space and says success here could ease
some of the public's concerns we believe
strongly in you know healthcare being
the first adopter of this type of
technology because there's a very
tangible and tremendous benefit there
right now we're talking about drones
delivering blood but think of it more
generally as drones delivering medical
supplies and when you do that you know
there's a whole world out there that you
can sort of change
proving the sky is not the limit for CBS
this morning media vol palo alto
california they do things different in
palo alto don't they it is wholly
different world they're always thinking
outside the box
very nice Matea thank you